the physicality of the queen is very
distinctive it was the glasses that
always pulled the whole thing together
i think she um is just a woman and a
mother
and a wife and a daughter and also
happens to be the queen of england
her hair there's only one woman in the
world with that hairdo
no member of the royal family will speak
publicly about this this is a private
matter
when you read critical books and
uncritical books and you start
finding a consensus down the middle you
know there was
this personality that started revealing
itself to me
who was honest and decent
and fun-loving and warm
above all responsible to her duty as the
monarch
and everything else had to take second
place to that
including her family do you suppose i
could borrow it
for a couple of days just a practice
it wasn't the real crown it wasn't the
real crown jewels
and but genuinely you really do have to
hold yourself properly and
i did have to practice with it quite a
lot i didn't put it on and go oh
my god i have found my place i it wasn't
like all of a sudden i realized that i
you know it was very impressive and
really beautiful replica actually
and also it didn't really fit so it was
a bit wiggly wobbly and we had to stuff
it with lots of stuff to make it fit
because jared wears the same crown
so um i didn't fit him either well
yes playing queen hand's much easier
because no one remembers what she was
like
so i could sort of do anything but queen
elizabeth
everybody knows you know her hair
there's only one woman in the world with
that hair do yes how is it taking over
for somebody who was impersonating the
woman
i literally for the first few weeks did
do an impression of claire
i thought i was just trying to channel
claire and then um uh
now don't know what i'm doing now but um
it's so much fun to do
[Music]
i met the queen very briefly about five
six years ago
and i was lucky that i met her in an
environment in a situation that she was
very relaxed in
and so she was relaxed and happy and
having a good time
and she was absolutely charming and
twinkly
and sweet i think it's very very easy to
see us just strong but i think she's
many many other things i think she's
very very vulnerable
and there's a strength there but she
doesn't see that as a quality in herself
i don't think people do
and real strength real fortitude and
kind of endurance
and that generation was very like that
anyway they were very keep calm and
carry on
really i think that would be
presumptuous of me to imagine that you
know playing the part
would would i i would have any insight
into what it's actually like
that's a lifetime of
having to be a certain way i can only
imagine
you know it's been an honour to play it
but i i wouldn't dare to
presume you don't think i would have
preferred to grow up
out of the spotlight away from court
away from the scrutiny and visibility
a simpler life i was very drawn to the
the queen as a young girl
and realizing that the true personality
of this little girl
was even before she became queen
full of a sense of responsibility a
sense of doing it
the right way doing the right thing in
the right way
and i think she still is that little
good girl
trying her best to do the right thing
in a very formalized world and not
wanting to betray that tradition
or that history it's amazing to see her
starting out and
figuring out how on earth to do this
monumental task that was ahead of her
and that it's good to realize that she
was scared and that she was unprepared
and that she's human
um if i met the queen i'd quite like to
ask her what other jobs she would have
liked
had she had a choice um
yes i think everybody says what's in her
handbag but i don't care what's in her
handbag
i'd i'd quite like to know what she
would have liked to have been if she'd
been able to choose what she wanted